[Music]  all right got my eyes turn you get some  lotion in it what I got it yeah you  probably sweated some lotion down in  happens filled up we live right  yeah that group over there we already  hit pretty good so we can move over in  front we were just kind of floating  around in here for the time being  [Music]  you know we're launching  I have an extra large yes I do I have a  medium I have a medium right here sir  tiny boy podcast like 500 subscribers  all right  if you see any iron with these shirts  right that is for the factorial Sunday  he just started  Sunday  you wanted to play  it's just around basically they're gonna  be giving away a digital copy whatever  platform or lack of your PlayStation  that's cool if your Xbox that's cool and  DC that's cool dude well it's not really  cool  with what I'm walking this way are we  having rage  [Music]  [Music]  he's got  that's it  oh boy easy guys  called the room the real one real weight  the fake thing chick weed that fake